funny thing Billy Batson Shazam he's a
team he's a Titan not a Teen Titan I'm
not a strange Teen Titans go to the
movie Teen Titans go to the movies is an
animation I believe is based on Teen
Titans go or that was really stupid i
phrase that horribly so I'm gonna go
ahead and back it up and correct that it
is based on Teen Titans go Teen Titans
go is in fact in the title of this movie
that's like saying I believe the Muppets
movie was based on the Muppets it's in
the title I guess I'm just trying to
make the point I never watched Teen
Titans go and you don't have that thing
that makes me go this isn't how it's
supposed to be animated which a lot of
people in this trailer dropped they had
that so Teen Titans go to the movies is
an animated comedy that looks like
Powerpuff Girls and Teen Titans had a
kid this is what happens when Teen
Titans go to the movies when Teen Titans
go to a straining service to the
structure but this more focus is on
Robin and how he doesn't want to be in
Batman shadow anymore really he wants a
movie made about him so he and the Teen
Titans embark on how to make that happen
that's the short version that's what you
get for the review I mean if you look at
the absurd promise of the Teen Titans
want a movie made about them because all
the other superheroes have movies made
about them with all the hat tips for the
other superhero movies a plot itself is
meta so it lends itself to a lot of meta
joke which is just like the thing to do
in comedies but it does make us laugh if
done right I feel like this movie does
it right sometimes I'm like you're
referencing Marvel I didn't know you can
even do that legally i legit laughed a
lot in this movie with this movie like
all right let's be the creepy adult ver
alone to watch a movie there's a lot of
comedy there for adults a lot of comedy
for kids too also adults if you're
looking at the plot it's really
predictable once you start seeing where
it's going we'll go ahead and say the
plot construction isn't there for adults
it's there for kids however I give this
movie credit for actually having a lot
of brains and heart I mean it's the
classic tale of friendship and what it
means I mean the lesson in this movie of
be okay with who you are don't try to be
something else or someone else have have
you be enough sounds really cliche as
I'm saying it right here it was executed
in a really interesting way that made me
laugh this movie was also great
commentary on Hollywood action movies
superhero movies so the meta humor in
here serves a point in purpose it's not
just you know because it's cool alright
there's some of it was there cuz it's
cool one song comes on when they're
doing a quest and I was like I don't
know how they're playing this song on
this life's probably expensive I can say
that but even the one
who's playing the voice of Superman that
cracked me out it's kind of a kin to the
Lego movies also and I'm locked out of
this movie I was like the movie I would
compare this one to are the lego movie
in that same way the more you know about
the properties the funnier is gonna be I
know some longtime Teen Titans fans were
kind of put off by the animation when
the trailer dropped cuz they were like
that is not the animation I remember not
my Teen Titan hashtag not my Teen Titans
that soundest algin I completely and
totally get it maybe that's why I'm able
to look past it because that's Teen
Titans weren't my thing necessarily but
if you're able to look past it and just
give into this movie you'll then be able
to experience what I think is a
genuinely enjoyable and funny movie kids
and adults alike can enjoy it I was like
Teen Titans go to the movies it was a
great time no alcohol required
be honest I'll probably buy it when it
comes out on blu-ray so there you go I'm
even the last line of this movie is kind
of trollish and it does it makes me
laugh with a thought that parents are
gonna have to deal with that after the
movie I can't help but tip my hat like
good for you guys so Teen Titans go to
the movies have you seen it what did you
think about it or what's a movie you
thought was gonna be horrible you walked
out actually having a really good time
whatever it is whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]